at bat since 1901 the Oakland Athletics
have called the East Bay home for half a
century but of late they've been
sporting a new-age attitude with four
playoff appearances in the last seven
years and a bonafide numbers crunching
approach in a game where stats mean
everything as showcased in the 2011 film
Moneyball if we try to play like the
Yankees in here we will lose to the
Yankees out there it's a great way to
connect with fans now president Dave
cavil is pitching a new deal to a city
left behind by its two other pro sports
teams a brand new stadium that wouldn't
cost taxpayers a dime we're committed to
privately financing the ballpark it's
been a guiding principle and a key point
of our project from the beginning the
extras are so out of the box he's
betting City Hall won't pass up the
bargain the A's want to foot the bill
for a splashy new ballpark and also
build 6,000 new housing units in Oakland
with the promise that many would be
affordable how do you get up to speed
when you haven't been a housing
developer well I think we're a sports
team but it's bigger than baseball and
we want to make sure that our project
and everything it brings to the Oakland
community a new neighborhood housing
including affordable housing that makes
sense for our community and any big
project is going to need to include
these aspects for it to be successful
Oakland Mayor Libby Schaaf is more than
eyeing the project she's nearly sold
housing is the number one need in the
Bay Area right now housing at every
income level but especially affordable
housing for our workforce just how
affordable is affordable so these are
things that will be worked out along the
way give me a ballpark you know I think
that somewhat somewhere between 25 and
45 percent would be appropriate for a
development like this it's an attempt to
ease what's dubbed the Silicon Valley
effect a housing crisis in San Francisco
experienced a decade ago
that's crept across the bay median home
prices in Oakland's metro area have more
than doubled in the
10 years to nearly 700 $63,000 renter up
83% during that same time last year the
average rent in Oakland topped $2,600 a
month that's more expensive than
Washington DC Seattle and San Diego do
you see this as unprecedented territory
well I think it is a new way to look at
ball park development and I think it's
great that we're working in Oakland
Oakland has always been a city on the
vanguard of new ideas and new projects
the A's know just how hard it is to find
housing in the Bay Area they've been
looking for a new home for decades but
Coliseum is baseball's fifth oldest
stadium and it's been plagued with
structural problems we need a new home
one that can generate the type of
revenue so we can invest in our players
win more world championships and have
success on and off the field
we had three final sites and I think
this one was always the most iconic the
waterfront location cavil showed us
where the A's hope to build that Stadium
and neighborhood Howard Terminal an
industrial waterfront area adjacent to a
retail district in Jack London Square
the team also wants to redevelop the
site where they currently play building
a mixed use neighborhood and
transforming the Colosseum's playing
field into a park so do you see this as
a model for what stadiums and teams
should be looking to do in the future
well we spent almost a year working with
the community doing outreach we've done
24 community workshops we've listened to
the community and understood what their
concerns are I know they're listening
Esther Goolsbee is a member of Oakland
United just one of the local groups that
have taken part in dozens of community
workshops hosted by the A's Oakland
United believes that any development by
the A's should result in a community
benefits agreement that would provide
jobs for local residents affordable
housing and investments in community
services if Oakland A's are truly rooted
in Oakland then a strong community
benefits agreement no matter or West
Oakland would happen they are not some
fly-by-night developer that's going to
build something sell and get out of town
they know that their brand depends on
community goodwill but the Howard
terminal site is far from a home run if
the plan goes forward it will need an
extensive environmental cleanup if you
do this and you do it right what are the
benefits
well more World Championships is
hopefully a key benefit so let's forget
about the A's for a minute here let's
talk about what this could mean for
Oakland well what it means for Oakland
is jobs economic development over three
billion in economic stimulus from this
project alone five thousand new jobs
you know a huge investment privately
ballpark informing ballpark 2020
fantastic got it right there 2023 is the
time they want to open you know he's
done this with the soccer team that is
development opened owns rather a new
stadium in San Jose and really still a
lot of hurdles here's my project though
so ambitious and and it's so nice to see
a team wanna do this privately and help
the community it's the only way to do it
in California those California lawmakers
and mayors they're just not having
anything anything but I believe that
before yeah follow that blueprint